you
[Music]
I'm going to talk about introducing data
downtime in the path from firefighting
to winning I'll explain shortly what
that means a little bit about myself
I've been the vice president of customer
operations at gain site for the last
couple of years gain site is a customer
data company prior to that I was at Bain
& Company as a management consultant
before that I was also in the Israeli
Air Force as a commander of a data
analyst unit and the most important
thing to know about me is that I am a
die-hard fan of Bruce Willis every
single movie come talk to me about that
after so I want to tell you guys a story
about actually a pretty difficult time
for me professionally this was back in
2016 I don't know if this this is
familiar to anyone but at the time at
gain site I see heads nodding that's
good at the time against that I was
leading a team responsible for customer
data and analytics I mean part of a
responsibility we actually had
dashboards and metrics that went
regularly to the board to our executives
and to our customers as well and I think
there was like this three weird three
week period where literally it was like
the perfect storm I think like it felt
like every week I woke up to like 10
different emails about something else
that went wrong with the data this could
be anywhere from like engineering push
new code which which had a bug which
impacted the specific dashboard -
someone made a change in the field name
really just like a myriad of things it
just all went wrong at the same time and
I think the thing that was hardest for
us as a team was that we were never
actually the team catching this right it
was actually like other people letting
us know about this people from like
folks from our CEO taxi customers and
that was really frustrating actually I I
wasn't sure we're gonna get out of it
but after basically like 10 days of work
working straight through the weekend my
team remembers this time you know we
were able to reach a stabilized point
now our CEO at the time was very patient
but some CEOs are not as patient
actually met I met a founder CEO told me
that he regularly like on a weekly basis
goes around the office with sticky notes
saying like this is wrong and like
post this on data with like with with
analytics so you know you get you get
both extremes so in any case you know it
sounds like this is a familiar thing and
for anyone who's actually in data for a
while this sort of actually becomes like
kind of like the state of the norm right
we sort of like accept it it's yeah this
is part of like what it's like to deal
with data right and there's some some
good articles and medium talking about
this and getting more and more traction
and honestly this happens to like teams
both small and large right like this is
just from a month ago
Google's bad data wiped another
neighborhood off the map yeah pretty
pretty hilarious right but like I guess
our data is 100% reliable like said no
and ever right so what are we actually
doing about this some some teams you
know try to find like creative ways to
handle this problem over to someone else
right the data engineers are like no no
this is a data analyst problem the data
scientist are like no no this is a data
analyst problem and the executives are
like what's going on right so some teams
do actually like start to proactively
think about this actually like will add
some manual some annual checks and tests
and teams that are really you know want
to get get around this problem will
spend significant amount of resources
and time this is an example of someone
who's worked on this for a company
that's worse than this for an entire
year talks to you reach this
stabilization point that's a significant
investment from a company perspective so
what I'd like to actually propose here
is that while this problem is really
prevalent a lot more prevalent than we
care to admit I don't think that we're
actually treating it with the diligence
that it demands and I think we're it's
maybe it's part of like this stigma of
having wrong data that we're trying to
avoid like sort of feels uncomfortable
to get on stage and say oh man my data
was really wrong for a while there and
uh you know and I do think in order to
get her to get around this and to really
address this problem we have to start
talking about it and I'd like to propose
a new name for it that actually I think
gives it the the gravity that it
deserves I'd like to call it data down
time so data downtime refers to periods
of time when your data is partial arañas
missing or just otherwise inaccurate
now why date a doubt in time borrowing
sort of from the conflict concept of the
early internet days so going back a
couple day decades ago when the internet
was new having your website up was like
not such a big deal maybe you had a web
maybe you had an online application
maybe not right
um and so if your online application was
done was down it just wasn't a big deal
like you could afford that right fast
forward to today like no such thing
right like everybody's like meticulously
measuring downtime and uptime of their
online applications and you know
companies invest a lot of effort in
making sure that everything is running
at all times so I'd like to propose that
in the same way if you guys at the point
that we are now today in time if you
guys fast forward a couple of decades
from now I think we're gonna see that
we're gonna have to treat data in the
same way that we've treated online
applications back then I think data is
gonna become much more critical to our
day-to-day operations going to rely on
it's similar in the same way that we
rely on our online applications and
we're gonna have to meticulously invest
in actually figuring out how to make
sure that our data is up and valid and
accurate so um in this talk I'll cover a
little bit about what I think about the
risks our data downtime I got a lot of
nods here so it sounds like it's sort of
familiar maybe if you can just do like a
quick raise of hand like who experienced
a to down time in their company at some
point or in the past yeah that's like
100 percent and yet we're all sort of
you know I don't want to say complacent
but we've kind of accepted it right so I
want to talk about why I think this is
important and I've also to show you guys
from kind of my perspective what
companies are doing to address this
today and I'd love to get your thoughts
after if there's like any other any
other amazing solutions that you guys
know of
so a couple signs of you're experiencing
data downtime time spent on fire gels
actually talked to CTO of a marketing
tech company who told me that his entire
engineering team consists of about 200
engineers spend something like 30% or
more of their time and I'm talking like
weeks and days not just hours on fire
just that's a significant drink now that
doesn't actually count for the morale
impact that this has right that's that's
another sort of area that we probably
want to think about and quantify another
example is actually an ad tech company
that basically charges their customers
based on based on their usage they got
the usage wrong they found this out a
couple of months later which basically
translated to them under charging the
customer by a couple million dollars
that's really significant right that's a
big deal
Netflix in 2015 was down for 45 minutes
in some parts that's like that's pretty
bad right and so that was like she'd do
to duplicate data and I'll talk a little
bit more about what what they put in
place in order to to deal with that
another example here is actually a a
debt collection company that basically
relies on data from third party company
from 30 organizations to give them
information about debt to collect you
can imagine how every delay or problem
with that data not in a span of like a
couple of hours of troubleshooting but
actually a couple of minutes in which
they don't actually know who to collect
money from and and how much that's a
significant impact for them so they
actually measure the troubleshooting
time in out in minutes not in hours and
not in days actually another another
person I talked to told me that their
data analysts spend so much time
troubleshooting that they started
tracking the numbers quantifying it and
then putting it back into costs for the
product team to Canfor so basically like
product team was accountable for that
metric so really creative ways kind of
to get around this but I think you guys
sort of hopefully get the sense that
this is kind of beyond you know one team
or one organization it's really
impacting our ability to sort of deliver
meaning
full value to our clients and also to
help our teams internally so what can we
do about it as I mentioned I really
believe that this is a very big problem
I think we talk a lot about like privacy
and security and self-service analysis
sort of self-service analytics and a lot
of other things that we can do with data
but fundamentally if you don't get the
data right that's a problem for everyone
right and that's that's actually like I
think it's one of the biggest barriers
if not the biggest one to the data
industry as a whole and I'd propose that
you know for us here are passionate
about the data industry actually make
this part of our agenda make this part
of our day-to-day operations you know
figure out what your data debt is and
actually pay it have this part of your
weekly meetings part of your agenda
maybe even part of your roadmap another
way is to actually think about data
downtime is a good way to measure your
team's effectiveness if you guys are
actually responsible for data a many
times I talked to folks who told me
while we've improved so much in our data
capabilities over time we don't really
have a way to show that right we don't
have a way to like explain how our team
can shine so if you guys go back to your
teams and actually figure out a way to
measure this and then to show progress
for data downtime over time that's an
amazing way to show to showcase how
you're teaming shining in the
organization and bringing value so in
the last last cup of monster thinking
through what I call sort of a maturity
model for data downtime so this is Basin
kind of conversation with hundreds of
companies dealing with data dealing with
data downtime and trying to classify
what's actually kind of the journey that
people go through as they deal with this
and a couple of pattern a couple
interesting patterns and I hope that as
we go through this a couple of things
for you guys to keep in mind so one
where would you place yourself right
like I'm super curious if I could do a
survey you know maybe ask you guys at
the end like how many folks are in which
stage how much attention do you guys
actually put to this and then the second
thing to put to to keep in mind is what
some of the tools that other teams were
doing the things that other folks are
thinking about that you want to take
back to your organization and to
implement so the very first stage is
sort of the reactive stage that's gonna
the the stage where you're really kind
of in this ongoing crisis mode right
like every day there's another email
there's lots of stuff coming are you
really kind of like running around like
headless chickens trying to figure out
what's going on once you sort of figure
out the how problem you move the bracket
of stage right in the proactive you're
actually starting to put together some
pretty basic manual checks it requires
discipline this part it actually
unfortunately requires a lot of folks to
change the way that they operate and
make sure that they include this in your
your code in your processes and then
once you sort of figure out that you
want to take it to the next level the
automated stage is where you actually
have greater coverage and thinking about
this in a more programmatic way and more
automatic way the last stage is really
when it comes to sort of substantial
coverage it's a it's a lot more about
kind of managing all of your different
data sources and data types and really
having more of an embedded way to to
validate the data to make sure that you
don't have data downtime so I'll walk
through examples of what teams do in
each of these I'm gonna skip the
reactive stage because just a painful
one but you guys can just assume that
there's not much not much going on in
the reactive stage one thing actually
that's interesting is I spoke to lots of
folks who told me like I hear this a lot
you know in my previous two companies we
were reactive all the time like really
reactive and now I'm in a new company
this is my first role here and this is
going to be the first thing that I'm
gonna get right like I'm not gonna
repeat the mistakes that I made in the
past two and I think that's awesome
like I think that's that's really cool
that means you can skip the first couple
ones all the way from from the beginning
that's that's huge value yet so a couple
of examples for what folks do in the
proactive stage so starting out with
like
again these are just examples currently
give you guys a taste of what it's like
obviously like there's a lot more out
there but a couple of examples one is
pretty basic best practice say you have
a weekly dashboard that you know your
your board or executives are you're
using every week you want to make sure
that you're generating the data a couple
of times that week so that if there's an
issue you can catch and recover from
from it pretty quickly
another thing that folks do is you know
manually actually write QA queries for
example on timestamps to make sure that
the data is fresh if you're looking at
if you're sort of generating data from
different sources making sure that there
is a source of truth at this point and
then doing something like validating row
counts in critical parts of in critical
parts of your pipeline and I'll walk
through an example of that so this is
sort of an example of kind of a pretty
basic architecture typical architecture
where you have a data source or maybe a
couple data sources this can be like
usage data customer or transaction data
or website visits
and then you sort of have a jobs you
could have send that to data warehouse
that can be something like redshift or
snowflake and then you have a couple of
jobs to then do transformation
aggregations on the data and essentially
what you can do is basically validate
something really basic like just the
number of rows for your key tables those
that either tend to break most often or
those that you're sort of watching or
using most commonly in your decisions to
make sure that that's within reasonable
range that you'd expect and one thing to
consider here that I think is pretty
interesting is whether you actually fail
the job completely sort of stop the
transmission of data versus generate a
warning and alert continue to send the
data but have someone actually look at
it to make sure that it's you know it's
within a reason and you can sort of
continue with your with your normal
operations
so I'll just trade-offs to think about
now if you want to take this to the next
step
you can actually track more things than
row counts you can track a set of
metrics you can store them in essential
like influx a sort of a time series
database and then actually create some
sort of centralized place that you can
then drive visibility off of it so this
is you know if you guys can have like a
dashboard that you look at this and
create reporting and even alerting on
this so what is this actually effective
to do well it's effective when Rome
count actually matters to your data and
Road count is a good predictive
predictive measure of issues if you guys
think you know I think some teams this
can help catch like you know forty or
fifty percent of the really big problem
the limitation is that obviously like
this is manual it requires maintenance
and and tuning and obviously doesn't
catch all the issues definitely it's not
not sensitive to sees it is sensitive to
seasonality so so something to consider
so then in the third stage the more
automated stage where it's more
programmatic way of thinking and
designing this also starts enforcement
of specific behaviors that you would
expect or not expand so starting by
first of all tracking a set of metrics
and also tracking them automatically so
it doesn't require sort of the manual
effort or less of it about dimensions
and measures and then starting to look
at those tracking those historically
basically looking at metadata over time
and comparing to past periods to see if
there's something they you know you need
to be concerned about um some team have
a data health dashboard that they report
on every week that they look at every
week and it can be something simple like
red yellow green to just explain whether
you're making progress or not and then
starting starting to think more about
data downtime be on a particular team so
I think the minute that you start sort
of documenting and creating a
centralized place for everyone to see
how you align on the data it allows you
to take it out of your particular team
whether that's data engineering and
engineering or data
analysts are data scientist team and
then expanded to the entire organization
so by having visibility um it actually
helps you rally other teams around this
and helps you communicate that this is
an important thing that we want to
figure out so I think that's the big
sort of benefit of documentation here
and then sort of another good example I
think is sort of both monitoring and
enforcing schema and validity of of
upstream so talk about that one for a
bit so why would you want to do this
what are some of the reasons and perhaps
it's obvious but data sources change
they can be you know a schema change the
data sources can get added can be
updated can be dropped I think if
there's one constant thing that we can
all say about our data is that it just
never stays the same right we always
keep on adding updating it I mean so
that's just the reality um the second
thing is that often the data actually
doesn't the data team doesn't have
visibility into what's happening
upstream I think a lot of teams have
improved on that you know I talked to
this company that told me we make such a
big deal of every change that
engineering makes that it's like the
biggest announcement almost like we
close a new customer or like I made a
really big change in our feature like
literally the engineering team like goes
out to the entire organization and like
announces to data organization and
announces it they do rca's on root cause
analysis on every data issue really sort
of make that issue part of the
engineering culture as well how do you
actually do that so starting by defining
the expected schema and then actually
validating against a schema
when before processing new data and then
probably you know either allowing the
user or making a decision about whether
you want to totally discard the data
send it to a separate isolated database
and or alert on it so this is a tool
that segment released not too long ago
it's called protocols I think this
actually
this tool actually started because they
notice that their customers are doing
this documentation of schema in Excel
like literally typing in maybe some of
you guys are doing that as well I
certainly did that
and so they realized why don't we help
automate that and actually take it to
the next level and allow folks to
enforce the schema that they've defined
in Excel so this is an example of a
tracking plan where you basically can
have define your events a description of
what those are specify what data type
like a string or an integer I think they
have there or a number and basically
create visibility so that everyone sort
of is aligned on this and then as I
mentioned what you can also do is that
whenever sort of your before your
processing data if there is invalid or
unplanned events you can basically
decide to take action based on that can
either alert on that discard it or or
just send it to to another database so I
think this is pretty cool like for folks
for folks using I think it's pretty
nifty the limitations of it is obviously
that it works for segment data so for
data that you're not processing a
segment I still have to think about that
so taking this to the next level that
bonus and moving beyond validating your
structure of the data to actually
validating the content of the data so
this is an example of a pretty cool
open-source tool called great
expectations I think actually Abe Gong
is gonna be here tomorrow so you guys
have questions you can ask this you can
ask him but I think I think this is a
really cool really cool open source
encourage you guys to check it out and
basically what allows you to do is
encode in Python expectations that you
have about the data and then basically
like understand and the line on whether
your data falls in place with that with
those expectations so in this example
you basically declare your expectation
about about column values to be between
a specific range
what's the allowed percentage of data
that you're expecting to not be in range
or that's okay to not be enrage so for
example if you have a group of 10 people
and you're looking at shirt sizes and
you expect shirt sizes to be between 0 &
7 and you think you know up to 70% of
the data needs to be within that range
you can define that in code and then run
run your data on it um
I think you know the limitations of this
or the challenges of this is first of
all it requires you to actually really
understand your data which you'd be
surprised
doesn't always have been right or takes
time especially if you're just getting
started and the second limitation is
that it is manual and requires you to
update it if your data set changes if
there's seasonality so just just
something to consider another bonus for
teams who are thinking about actually
creating alerts based on this sort of
like the the nightmare scenario is when
there was like this one person who's
like bombarded by all these alerts or
maybe it's a certain team and then you
know there starts to kind of alert
fatigue you're not sure if the day if
the alert is right or not like am i
right is he alert right am I wrong
what's going on and like you know
actually like going through all of them
can be can be quite tedious for teams
who want to figure out how to streamline
some of this it would actually take a
shot at sort of the lineage and assign
ownership at the beginning so that every
kind of assign ownership to like
specific pipeline and specific tables so
that you can actually send the the alert
to the right person from the get-go cool
so that was the first three stages in
the fourth stage here this is kind of
taking it from we moved from sort of
manual checks to more programmatic
holistic way to think about it to then
actually doing this at scale so one
thing that you could start thinking
about is actually validating these
measures across different tables meaning
if you are looking at something like
revenue
if you're trying to calculate revenue in
a couple of different places you'd
expect revenue to correlate across all
of those places and so starting to track
that can be really helpful another thing
that people are starting to do is
actually like track and annotate issues
so for example if I was looking into
something in just a particular data
issue like let's say our data dropped
three years ago due to some world crisis
actually that happened
I'd like to annotate that so that the
next person will know and that it's you
know it's they're not gonna come to me
again and again for the question and if
I'm not there which is always the case
it's always like the question you know
the person that you're looking for is
never there
it's like Murphy's Law and another thing
that you can do is also start actually a
tracking questions I think Airbnb has a
nice platform for this where you can
basically see like what questions folk
task folks asked and tracked that as I
mentioned some teams are actually
starting to use JIRA for this so have
like run books have like priority p1 p2
p3 to data issues and really treat them
in the same way that they would treat it
like an issue or a bug and then finally
here embed automated data validation
across your pipeline I'll show a couple
examples the idea here is again sort of
having this part of your ongoing
operations and having it a scalable as
much as possible so this is an example
that was developed in an eBay Patchi
Griffin it's an example of a very
scalable way to do this so basically
there are some pre-built tests that you
can use but it also allows you to define
your own measures and your own metrics
and you can run this on both batch and
streaming see Kafka and basically you
have automatic reports and measurements
generated for you which you can then
build alerts on top of so it's pretty
cool the the limitations of this I think
are in that it does actually
a part of it it does actually require
defining the data quality measures that
you're looking for but last I believe
they were running this on I think 800
million records a day which is pretty
insane so um yeah this is just I think a
very cool example of how to do this
programmatically and it's scale and this
is another example from Netflix which I
heard gave a great talk today so this is
you know Netflix as you know in in their
instance actually the requirement here
is to validate like tens of thousands or
hundreds of thousands of metrics and you
can't really account you can't not
account for seasonality you know I don't
know if there's like who's watching
video I don't know like Friday night
everything spikes and then Monday
morning right or you know specific a
month of the year etc so you it's
actually really important to account for
seasonality so Netflix developer rad
robust anomaly detection they published
this online can check it out basically
what they do is they use pretty cool
these are PCA or bus PCA algorithm to
detect detect anomalies what you see
here on the left side is actually random
data set and the algorithm based on it
and the circles there are actually the
anomalous points so first of all I think
it's a pretty cool way of detecting
anomalies the second thing is that and I
think this is the coolest part is that
they actually use a pig wrapper that
allows allows folks to basically with
one line of code include this and their
pipelines and validate key metrics so I
think that's awesome and that basically
gets you out of the sort of manual part
of it and allows you to to have it
really embedded and easy to use I think
also the specific examples that they've
seen success in this is pretty cool so
as you can imagine Netflix processes
millions of transactions from banks
across the world and so they actually
use this to identify at the Bank level
specific transactions that they need to
address and then folks in actually reach
out to sort of their their payment
counterparts and and address those
specific issues and they're doing a
increased scalable way the second
example is so as you can imagine Netflix
users basically signup to Netflix in
very different devices different
browsers different countries and so they
can use this to look at combinations of
user country and browser to identify
like at the user level what signup
problems happen so they can improve
their signup conversion rates basically
and address those anomalies or failures
so bringing this all together I'm
actually really curious maybe we can do
like a quick show of hand
we'll see if you guys how shy are you
guys today who'd put themselves in in
the reactive State nice it's either you
or a friend you can answer for a friend
okay who sees himself or a friend in the
proactive stage okay about I want to say
30 40 % we have like 10 percent or so
and reactive 34% proactive how many in
the automated stage Oh interesting what
is this 15%
something like that pretty cool how many
in the scalable one one knows you saved
us that's amazing
very cool well look um I hope this was
helpful instead of understanding where
you guys are but also sort of figuring
out like where you want to be in the
future right like where do you think
your company needs to be so I would
suggest that you guys like figure out
where we are where I am today where I
need to be and how do I get there
figure out like what are the tools
open-source or not that you want to they
want to incorporate that take that and
put that as part of your roadmap right
like treated with the diligence and the
seriousness that that's required and and
let me know how it goes because I'm
really curious if you do figure this out
you will kick ass and I'm here
first of all allows you to minimize fire
drills but more importantly direct that
time and energy towards revenue
generating features though towards other
high priority high critical and high
priority items it also actually help you
gain a competitive advantage against
others in the market in enabling your
entire company to become data-driven
think there's nothing worse than like an
executive team or even a whole company
that's trying to become data-driven this
founder told me a couple of months ago
that they really wanted to be
data-driven but they were just so
plagued by data issues that people were
like the data is wrong and this sucks
like we just don't want to really use
this and we'll just go with our
intuition which I think happens a lot so
if you guys actually figure this out
this will truly enable you guys to
deliver a better value for your
customers and actually I think something
that's like contrary to popular belief I
think if you do this well it doesn't
actually slow you down with a lot of
overhead but rather allows you to move
faster because you're more confident
that you're not actually breaking
everything well along the way and you
get to say I crushed it so I'd love for
the key takeaway or the key takeaway
that I have here is despite great
efforts from super smart people many
great teams I think data downtime is
still a challenge and still something
that happens everywhere and I think
there are actually lots of many hard
unsolved problems here and a great
opportunity and I do think that if we
rally together around this and sort of
figure it out it's going to be a huge
benefit not just for your companies and
teams but also for the data industry as
a whole so I
thing we have just a couple of minutes I
can take questions and office hours if
flood folks get to lunch but thanks so
much guys I have one so this this
journey really resonates with me so I
work for LinkedIn we have done a lot of
work to reduce our data downtime I think
and as the data science data that we
produce has gotten more reliable and
robust and valuable now other teams have
started relying on our data and so we
break them just like the engineering
teams used to break us nice and one
question that I have it I think
something that's still remaining very
difficult is knowing who the consumers
of your data are and how they are using
it to figure out who to notify so we can
blast out notifications to everyone this
thing is going to change but if we knew
this is the person who uses this field
in the way that we are about to break
them we could you know pin them down and
warn them more effectively yeah face on
that totally great question it's funny
how you always find yourself on like
both sides right it's it's an easy
transition and so first of all I will
say I don't think there's a silver
bullet at least I haven't seen one if
anyone has let me know but I don't think
there's a silver bullet I think folks
are still figuring that out
there's obviously data lineage solutions
that people are starting to develop and
I also know teams who in a very manual
and process oriented way have like
weekly check-ins with folks from each of
these organizations to talk about what
are the main changes that are coming up
and sort of like the headline of what's
the area that you want to be thoughtful
about so that's one way to think about
that another way that folks are starting
to think about this as you mentioned
like the blasting blasting uh warnings
but I think that works for smaller teams
certainly not for LinkedIn so yeah some
ideas but I just don't think that
there's a silver bullet yet
hi I really loved this talk
absolutely resonated with me as well so
my name is Claire I work at Fishtown
analytics and I'm the DBT community
manager and I'm not sure if you've heard
of DVT but I just kind of wanted to very
quickly talk about it because these are
things that we we think about a lot so
DVT helps I don't let's do like the
transformations in their warehouse and
in terms of some of these problems like
when we write our sequel you can also
write tests on your sequel anything that
you can express as a sequel query you
know things are unique things are not
know how many row counts there are like
it's just a yanil file for us so any of
the clients we work with we've got some
of our some community members who use
DBT I think next to me from envoy over
at gate lab periscope in the back there
hey um and we have a really good
framework around you know running your
tests when you submit a pull request
running your tests after every single
set of transformations in our latest
version that we released a couple weeks
ago we also introduced a concept of
sources where you could test the data
that's being put in your warehouse as
well not just your transformations and
also tests how fresh it is so the next
release as well we're going to be adding
more fine-grained controls that went
what's a warning what's an error so this
is something that I think about a lot
and I think yeah I just want to share
life we've got a few other people in the
room that use it as well so yeah I need
a slide for you guys next time I think
that's what I'm hearing alright thank
you so much for your talk definitely
resonated a lot of wealth co-founding
startup I think a lot of my recent
experience has been leading data teams
for companies that are at series B or
earlier mm-hmm so one of the thing kind
of the opposite the linkedin problem
right like the product itself that we're
instrumenting and measuring and
analyzing is changing with weeks so hmm
the schemas are changing the semantics
of the data are changing do you have any
advice as to how to approach that
problem especially in a context where
the ratio of data staff to product staff
is close to zero yeah
yeah great question so I think it's
interesting because there was like maybe
three or four things changing at once
like your company's changing so like the
team is changing basically right like
probably you guys are if you're growing
fast probably you guys are hiring a lot
you have new team members by the way
everything that like there's probably
like one data engineer maybe at some
point and like then he or she left so
like there's all the changes that right
with the team itself and the people the
product is changing as you mentioned
very quickly right and the data is
changing so the way that you guys are
thinking about data sources or your data
infrastructure is changing all the time
I think that is actually true to almost
all companies maybe some a little bit
differently on the people side but
actually like even large companies I'm
are growing their data team pretty
quickly is what I found in specific and
folks companies were trying to become
more data-driven so the good news is
that you're not alone I think lots of
companies experienced this change
regardless of their stage the less bad
news is again like I don't have a silver
bullet I think what people do today is
figure out how much how important this
is to them and then put put their
resources behind to figure that out so
for example if you have someone who's at
the sort of executive level to make sure
that it is a top company priority I
think the problem is that many times
it's like you know number 15 on the list
for someone and then it never actually
gets the right resources and not not
prioritized so I think some having
someone who's responsible and
accountable for it I mean the other
thing is that also like there isn't only
one person accountable for this and
whatever there's more than one person
it's like there's zero accountability so
actually having one person who's tasked
at figuring this out the person like
wakes up every day and like thinks
obsessively about it like how to do this
better I think that can also be be
meaningful and then I'd say the last
thing is like charting out a road map
and figuring out like what's the state
today what do we need to do and how are
we getting there and charting that way
that that would be my recommendation
[Music]